Speaker 1: All right let's look at so the
Durham report, this much anticipated Durham
report, which was going to blow the roof off
of all of the wrongdoing that was committed
against Donald Trump when he was being investigated.
Total nothing.
BURGER And we're going to look at this through
and interview.
This is actually really interesting.
Donald Trump was interviewed by fired Fox
News host Dan Bongino yesterday and Trump
told 2030 lies about the content of the Durham
Report.
This goes bad quick.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: I'm always excited to welcome back
to the show.
A man who hopefully will be the next president
of the United States, a good friend of the
show, a good friend to me personally, President
Donald J. Trump.
Mr. President, thanks for joining us.
Speaker 3: Right, Dan?
Speaker 1: Okay, so it's up.
Hello, Dan?
Trump in a bad mood.
Bad mood.
Trump is never good during interviews.
This has been written about extensively.
When Trump has that bad mood, he is a difficult,
difficult guy, so it gets off to a notably
bad start.
They go right into the Durham report and the
lies pouring out of Trump's mouth.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, we got the report
yesterday.
Everything you said was correct.
This is one of those hashtag Donald Trump
was right again moments, is it?
Sir, you you were framed.
You were framed.
They had no evidence of any of this from.
Speaker 1: There is no reason to believe Trump
was framed.
Speaker 2: Start your thoughts on that.
Speaker 3: They thought they were going to
lose and we were indeed framed.
And it really pertains more because they missed
the dates.
And amazingly, the report was it picked up
until just after the election.
Even remember, I think it was BuzzFeed, which
is now essentially out of business.
I understand, which is a very good thing for
the for the country to do this.
Speaker 1: But it's great when media outlets
go out of business per Trump.
Speaker 3: This was done sometime after the
campaign.
It actually affected, if you look at it and
it really study it, it really affected 2020
much work as we went through years of nonsense
with Russia, Russia, Russia.
I didn't even know what they were talking
about.
People would come up to me.
Sir, do you know anything about Russia?
Speaker 1: If you are not understanding this
word salad, do not adjust your television
or mobile phone or computer screen.
Nobody can understand what he's talking about
here.
Speaker 3: And after a while I would say,
what's going on with the Russia?
It was a frame up and these are bad people.
This is Schiff and Clinton and all these are
bad people.
But it was much more than them.
Marc Elias, you take a look at what they did.
And this really affected 2020 more than it
affected 23.
It was meant for 2016, but they couldn't get
it off.
You know, they had this fake dossier written
by Steele and who was offered millions in
order to try and get it confirmed and stick
with it.
Speaker 1: I'm going to go through all of
this with you in a moment.
Speaker 3: Couldn't get it confirmed.
You couldn't get anybody to confirm it because
it was all fake.
It was like you write a fiction book.
And but this really affected the 2020.
Another thing in the 2020 election, which
was totally rigged, by the way, incredibly,
they didn't want to talk about that then.
They didn't want to talk rich.
But, you know, all you have to do is take
a look at the 51 intelligence agency that
triggered it.
Take a look at truth, the vote.
These are great patriots.
Catherine Engelbrecht and these are great
patriots.
Went around for a year, took all of the tapes
out.
She sold all of these stuffing the ballot
boxes that took hundreds of thousands of votes,
stuffing the ballot boxes that took place.
And just you take a look at just Twitter and
the FBI, okay?
Speaker 1: So it goes on and on and on.
But let's add a little bit of reality to this.
Donald Trump and Dan Bongino and others would
have you believe that the Durham report exposed,
quite frankly, that the real crime was even
investigating Donald Trump and that Trump
is vindicated in all these different things.
I don't know how many of you have actually
looked at the Durham report, The Durham report,
in which they put all of their eggs in that
basket for years.
The Durham report found no evidence of any
deep state plot against Donald Trump the way
he claims it does not accuse the FBI or DOJ
of acting out of political bias.
It doesn't accuse the FBI or DOJ of acting
out of malice.
It doesn't allege any criminal wrongdoing
by anybody that was involved in the Mueller
probe, except for one low level lawyer who
pled guilty to altering an email in 2020 of
no consequence.
Big picture to the investigation.
The report did say some some aspects of how
the FBI handled the investigation, like they
opened the investigation on a tip from an
Australian diplomat.
They relied on some uncorroborated information.
They ignored elements of potentially exculpatory
evidence.
Yeah, there were procedural errors that the
Durham report found.
It is not indicative of any intentional misconduct,
political bias, a deep state plot, a conspiracy
against Trump, a frame up, a frame job framing
or any of it.
And none of that affected the validity of
the outcome of the investigation.
This is in the Durham Report and Trump and
Biden.
Bongiorno want you to pretend it's something
different.
The report repeated some debunked conspiracy
theories that were pushed by Trump.
For example, it wrongly claimed the Steele
dossier triggered the investigation.
That is not true.
That dossier didn't even get to the FBI until
September of 2016.
That was month three of the investigation
already.
So if you actually look at the Durham report,
you find that all of the stuff Trump is saying
simply isn't true.
Let's listen to just a little bit more of
this interview.
We're skipping ahead a little bit here.
Speaker 3: I call it the special persecutor,
not prosecutor, persecuted because persecuted
is worse, but Jack Smith and he continues
to go after Trump with the phony boxes hoax.
And if you take a look at Biden, Biden's got
boxes all over the place.
He had no right to declassify.
I do.
And but you just take a look, Jack Smith.
This is a continuation of the same hoax.
It's all a big hoax.
They're all friends.
They're in there, they're embedded.
And it's really a question.
It's right us and it's Democrats, radical
left Democrats.
I love the way you start your show with the
radical left.
You fight the radical left.
Speaker 1: All right.
So there has been no wrongdoing by the special
prosecutor that anybody has actually been
able to point to the idea that any Republican
that actually wants to look into what happened
is merely a RINO, A Republican in name only
is an old tired grievance from Donald Trump.
And the problem is, you look at the post,
if you look at this on troth central where
Trump posted it, people see this drivel and
then they post Wow, great show, great show,
Trump was right, etc. etc., etc..
They have fallen for it.
And Bongino is one of the henchmen that pushes
this nonsense on people.
Look at the Durham report and you'll see Trump
is lying.